the math psyche has begun to hallucinate
because because the destiny of human
beings is to live in the imagination in
the hands of the goddess and wherever
that thrust is impeded psychopathy will
resolve there will be neurosis there
will be psychic epidemic there will be
confusion so I believe that until we
form a resolution to conduct an
unfettered and mature exploration of the
human psychology using all the tools
available to us that the skies of Earth
will continue to be haunted by flying
saucers they will be contained they will
continue to be haunted by flying saucers
and their denizens because they are
symbols of our infantile ism of our
sense of loss of our incompleteness and
we can heal that breach by simply
recognizing that the true mystery lies
within us the true mystery is in the
mind and its historical promise is the
transformation of our society through
the abandonment of reason as it has been
narrowly defined by this extremely solar
masculine paternalistic materialistic
legacy that we are the victims of well I
could talk for a long time but I think
that's it in a nutshell
thank you expected eventually and when
is up to us it will no longer be a
higher dimensional object throwing a
shadow into the flat dimensions of
history it will be instead a
transcendental object made manifest we
are in fact on the brink of great
changes yes the UFO phenomenon has been
around for hundreds of thousands of
years possibly but nevertheless it is
somehow spun in to the fate of our
species and the overwhelming enemy of
self-transcendent flight of return to a
man Dalek unity that transcends space
and time is the guiding archetype of our
peregrination through history so I
believe that the UFO waits at the end of
time in the same way that the
individuated personality waits at the
end of the
logical development of the individual
and if we act in good conscience and
with great faith in each other we can in
fact realize the hope of the Irish
prayer which says mainly alive at the
end of the world thank you
[Applause]
[Music]